[Musique]
je suis Étienne Pouget je suis président
de chucketti
responsable du produit homequest et je
suis informaticienne et je gère nos
équipes à distance à Lille
[Musique]
ma crise se produit home Quest qui a
pour but de rassembler les gens autour
d'expérience d'aventure audio donc
vraiment c'est une console de jeux qui
va nous raconter des histoires dieux
dans lequel on nous serons les héros et
nous allons devoir résoudre une série
des mines pour progresser dans les
histoires et peut-être sauver le monde
et donc le mécanisme de jeu chaque
chapitre c'est un peu comme un escape
game on a une heure de jeu pendant
laquelle on va résoudre 5 à 10 énigmes
en coopération avec nos amis ou la
famille c'est un objet connecté il y a
pas besoin de wifi pour jouer mais les
objets ils sont vendus un kit de deux et
il se communique entre
[Musique]
notre premier prototype il s'agissait
d'un objet pour les Team Building et il
s'est déployé sur une table il se déplié
il se déplié sur une table et
sur Kickstarter et on a reçu plus de
1100 précommandes et en fait il y a 70%
de ses précommandes qui proviennent du
marché américain qu'on va vraiment
essayer de lancer en parallèle à la fois
en France et aux États-Unis
qui a réussi en juin 2022 alors nous
allons livrer le produit pour arriver à
avant Noël de cette année de 23
des contacts avec la presse américaine
ça c'est plutôt très bien passé et même
pas que la presse américaine puisqu'il y
avait des journalistes un peu du monde
entier qui sont présents lors du CES et
puis sur l'aspect distribution c'est la
même chose en fait c'est assez fou mais
on a eu des événements où on a pu
rencontrer des distributeurs du monde
entier aussi
[Musique]
et en pleine phase d'industrialisation
alors nous allons terminer
l'industrialisation lancer la production
cet été et livré à nos premiers clients
pour Noël de cette famille on aura les
premières livraisons donc on aura des
ventes en ligne sur notre boutique et
peut-être avec des partenaires pour la
vente en ligne mais après en magasin les
accords de distribution par exemple on
envisage de distribuer avec nature et
découverte ça ce sera probablement 2024